but before we go just time for admission
to the big red chair who is there hello
hi who are you I'm John John lovely I'm
where you from John I live in London
originally from Northern own ordinary
just outside belfast northern bangers
lovely banger it's not the seaside
resort lovely yes bringing it here down
I do what do you do here I try to make
it easier for people with disabilities
to bank - what - bang
my career guidance officer
that was suggested that to me
I can't wait we're here story now off
you go sir so I got up one morning as
usual getting myself ready to go to work
and from from getting I'd abandon the
twenty feet or so to get to the bathroom
I was excruciatingly peeing around the
the rectal region yeah
[Laughter]
dr. Clarkson's very concerned
and I think you should go to the ER I I
did go to the doctors got seen
straightaway and he says right can you
remove your trousers and underwear and
lie down and think happy thoughts so he
rummaged about and then yeah he asked me
a question do you like asparagus and
pulled out asparagus tip from my illness
bizarrely I had not eaten asparagus for
months
[Applause]
answers on a postcard
was that about
Danis his name yes to get in and then
get out because they're sort of weird at
the top on that I don't know did someone
break into his house an insert some his
because if he was cooked surely that
lovely hurt you wouldn't I don't
understand
[Laughter]
[Music]